The former
president, Donald Trump
had a lot to say tonight.
Many,
many of the things he said, of
course, were abjectly false.
A torrent of falsehoods
even from the get go.
CNN Sara Murray joins us now.
Her job tonight is fact checking.
So, Sara,
I'm not going to ask you to fact check
everything he said that was false.
Because we only have a couple more hours.
But but what what strikes you?
Well, you know, look,
I think one of the things off of the top
was that we heard
former President Trump again
say the election was rigged
and talk about ballot stuffing.
And, look, the reality is
the election was not rigged.
Biden won
by more than 7 million votes
and that ballot stuffing claim,
that was also bogus.
Here is Trump's
false claim on this tonight.
Out of the
people in this audience
and maybe a couple that don't.
But most people understand what happened
that was a rigged election.
And it's a shame
that we had to go through it.
Can you publicly acknowledge
that you did lose the 2020 election?
Let me just go on.
If you look at through the vote,
they found millions of votes on camera
on government cameras
where they were stuffing ballot boxes.
So with all of that,
I think it's a shame that what happened.
I think it's
a very sad thing for our country.
No, there is just no basis for this
claim. It is a lie.
We have heard it.
Trump claim
before that there was ballot
stuffing by election workers in Georgia.
It has been debunked,
including by Republican election
officials in Georgia.
There is no sign any illegality
like this occurred on a large scale
and multiple former Trump
officials, including Trump's own
former attorney general, Bill Barr,
have said there was not sufficient fraud
to change the outcome of the 2020
election Jake. Yeah, and that true.
The Vote Group is a group of unserious
right wing activists It is not
some sort of
objective election board.
It's amazing to hear them cited
as some sort of source.
Trump also claimed
he offered to send troops to the Capitol
on January six,
but House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
turned him down.
I don't think that's true. Sir.
No, not the case.
I mean, Trump has tried to blame
former House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
for the violence on January six.
He's falsely claimed
he ordered the National Guard
of the Capitol.
So here is Trump's
attempt to rewrite history tonight.
Says Miller wrote a book
and he's a fantastic guy
and he was ready to go.
They turned him down.
If you love the mayor
of Washington, D.C., lovely lady,
she said.
We don't want to
we don't like the look,
Nancy Pelosi said.
We don't like the look.
If they would have had just
I offered them 10,000 soldiers.
I said, it could be ten.
It could be more.
But I offered them
specifically 10,000 soldiers.
If they would have taken 500 soldiers,
you wouldn't have the problem.
They turned it down
Here is the reality.
The House speaker is not in charge
of Capitol security.
That's the Capitol Police Board,
which oversees the Capitol Police
and at the time of the riot
would have approved requests
for National Guard assistance.
And here is former
acting Defense Secretary Chris Miller
telling the January six committee
that he was never given
an order by Trump to have 10,000 troops
ready to go to the Capitol
on January six.
To be crystal clear, there was no direct
order from President Trump
to put 10,000 troops
to be on the ready
for January six crackdown.
Yeah, that's correct.
There was no direct
there was no order from the president.
So, Jake,
as you can see, these claims by Trump
about January six, also false.
Sara Murray thanks so much for that.
I'm sure you're going to have more
fact checks for us
because there were more lies
than I could count
said by the former president.
This evening let's talk about
one of the politically more impactful
decisions of his presidency
to put three conservatives
on the Supreme Court
that would ultimately overturn
Roe v Wade.
And what he had to say
about that tonight.
Kaitlan Collins was trying to get him
to say
whether he would sign
a national abortion ban
if he were reelected.
He wouldn't really take a position.
But here is what he said
about overturning Roe v Wade.
I consider the other side to be radical
because the other side
under Roe v Wade
and other things,
the other side, the radical,
because they will remember the debate
with Hillary Clinton.
I said rip the baby out of the womb
at the end of the ninth month.
They will kill the baby
in the ninth month.
If you look at that crazy governor,
of Virginia from the former governor
where he said, no, the baby will be born
and then we'll decide essentially
whether or not to execute.
Mr.
President,
can we talk about what you would do?
But these are the radical people.
Like,
obviously,
he would rather talk about positions
that Hillary Clinton
never took than his own position, which
is not supported by polls.
Just to be clear,
the things
you were saying about
Democrats are not true.
Hillary Clinton did not say anything
about ripping the baby out of the womb.
Let's just talk about the politics
of this Overturning Roe v Wade
is unpopular with the American people.
It's unpopular with the voters.
He needs to win the presidency
should he get the nomination.
He doesn't want to talk about this.
I don't know that
he's found a way to talk about it.
Now, that was pretty clear tonight.
And understandably,
there are so much to unpack
in this town hall.
But if he does get the nomination,
which is still a big if,
we're very,
very early in the process here,
he will have to face
a Democratic president
who has a White House and a campaign
who looks at the 2022 midterms
and believes that this is
exhibit A, B and C of why.
Yes, the economy is troubled. Yes.
That there are questions about Joe Biden,
but they still believe
that the abortion issue will drive voters
out to the polls.
To vote for Joe Biden
and to vote against Donald Trump.
If you take all the other issues, maybe
even all the other noise
and you put them aside,
that is still front
and center in voters minds.
And that answer, as you said, clearly,
if you are
the Trump campaign needs some refining.
I don't know they can refine it
before the end of the primary season.
Perhaps he will do it
if he gets the general not even refining.
I mean, he said I did that, I did that.
And that is not what Michigan,
Wisconsin, Michigan,
Wisconsin, Pennsylvania
swing voters want.
It seemed to me
that the goal tonight
for Trump
was to reinforce to conservative voters
that he supports the overturning of Roe
versus Wade.
Now, he did that to a point
that might have actually produced
quite a number of
of general election ads.
If he makes it to the general election.
But I think that's
what they were trying to do,
because
part of the context here
is that in the weeks leading up to this,
some of the reporting had been
that Trump's
aides were kind of saying or Trump
that was saying to his aides privately
that people like Ron DeSantis
had perhaps gone too far
with the six week abortion ban.
And when you saw Caitlin
pushing him on the date,
would he sign a federal abortion ban?
What weeks
would he support for an abortion ban?
He refused to answer those questions.
About the specifics.
They wanted to double down on
I support overturning Roe versus Wade
without getting him
tied down on anything concrete.
That is, by the way, happening
right now in the States.
These are not hypothetical situations.
And Trump
would not give the public
a clear answer about where he stands.
And in that respect
from the Trump campaign,
I'm sure
that they view
that as a victory in terms
of what he won in wanting to do
and how he executed.
Well, the phrase that he kept using
was it gave the Dobbs decision.
He called it a great victory.
He claimed,
of course,
that he had taken credit for it,
although, again,
if the Supreme Court
that actually ruled not the president.
Yeah, but he lived
He certainly did.
But the issue he was saying
was it gave pro-lifers
something to negotiate with.
Now, why that is so disingenuous,
is it one?
There were already trigger laws
that were on the books
that were created to be reinstated
or implement new abortion related bans.
Should Roe v Wade ever be overturned?
Number two,
of course,
the negotiation,
he presumes, does not happen
because you have mifepristone
now on the virtual chopping block.
You've got abortion bans under
partizan majorities in state legislatures
where there has been complaints
that there's no room to negotiate
on these very principles.
And so this perception
that the Dobbs decision
by returning to the states
somehow affords
a greater opportunity to negotiate
is one not with the Supreme Court
really was think well,
they may think about it,
but they didn't actually just say, well,
but also not
what's really happening on the ground.
But we can't lose sight of that.
One other thing I want to
I want to talk about is,
is his defense of the people
that were storming the Capitol
for Trump supporters died that day,
including one that was shot
by a police officer
who was protecting House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi.
He did his job.
They were bursting in.
Here is what he had to say about
that woman.
Hoo hoo
who's
who was led to the Capitol by
Donald Trump's lies
Over 140 officers were injured
that day,
and a person named Ashli
Babbitt was killed.
Yes. You know what?
She was killed
and she shouldn't have been killed.
And that thug that killed her,
there was no reason to shoot her
at blank range called blank range
shot her.
And she was a good person.
She was a patriot one.
There was no reason. There was no reason.
And he went on television to brag
about the fact that he killed her
Okay.
I mean, again, FactCheck,
he did not go on television
to brag
about the fact that he killed her.
He's not a thug. He's a police officer.
He was completely cleared
in the incident.
He was protecting the House speaker,
Donald Trump.
His lies in the lives of his minions
incited this crowd.
They violently burst in to the Capitol.
And yet
here he is taking the side of the mob
because he believes with his voters
this he has convinced his voters
to believe this.
And now he's going to stick with it.
Again, if you were
if you if any of you out there
watching thought
maybe he will pivot,
maybe he will change, he will not change.
He is who he is.
He wants to minimize this day.
And you heard Congressman Donald saying,
why do you keep asking about the 20,
20 election?
Why do you keep asking about January 6th?
We have to keep actually
if he is going to be
the Republican nominee,
or at least now
the formidable frontrunner
for the Republican nomination.
Yeah. They tried to steal the country.
They tried to steal the country.
They tried to undermine the foundation
of everything.
We can talk about abortion.
We can talk about taxes,
we can talk about infrastructure.
We can talk about swimming pools
in America.
If you want to regulate those,
you can't have an America
without a democracy.
Nothing else matters
if you take away the foundation.
That day was about trying to
steal the foundation.